est ce qu'on a vu pierre palmade essayer
de casser la gueule de patrick lors de
l'émission le grand bluff
oui non non c'est inverse barry meyer
celle inverse
bah oui il a une trouille ah mais c'est
et ça c'est un de mes moments de
techniques quand il en sort il est blanc
qui se sert alors on rappelle talent et
pg pierre palmade tu joues un fan je
fais un fan qui j'étais mais j'étais
d'ailleurs j'ai les épaules comme ça il
a vraiment eu à me regarder et jeudi
s'est passé pour un comique je raconte
une blague
c 'est n'allait rigole pas il rigole pas
je me mets en colère contre lui de ces
regarder les consommer quand on est
enfermé par ces gentils est en train de
répéter
j'étais aux attaquants pour qu'ils se
prennent à partie jeudi qu'il est en
train de reprendre son volant elle était
en sécurité s'il vous plaît tu peux pas
te défendre tout seul alors taper en
quoi années je me suis pas mal pourquoi
quand vous êtes page entière comment je
suis comme ils vont souza démarrer un
jour aller c'est est ce que vous avez
contre les comics
si j'avais quelque chose comme ça en
vaut les mots de pierre jeunet je me
suis je veux qu'il savait euro mettez
vous à la place je m'excuse émotions je
m'excuse non non c'est pas c'est pas une
blague
je vous connaissais patrick sébastien
vous connaissez pas ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a une heure de l'émission je me suis
embrouillé des épaules sur le récif
c'était énorme le grand bluff c'était
exceptionnel ce qu'on a vu serge
gainsbourg pleurer chez patrick
sébastien face à une chorale oui c'était
un grand moment je prie à l'internement
spectateurs sébastien c'est fou je vois
pas ça dans mon spectacle justement
battue en fait c'était j'ai pas fait ça
pour qu'il pleure je voulais lui faire
plaisir
on avait fait j'avais écrit une petite
chanson j'ai mis plein de gamins qui
avaient la fausse barbe la cigarettes en
chocolat et le jus de pomme est en fait
comme il n'y voyait plus très bien serge
temps qu'ils étaient loin d'aider qui
les a vus se rapprocher sa la salle à
regarder le bouleverser
[Musique]
nations unies changé
jus de jizane
[Musique]
vg
à jamais
[Musique]
j'en passe j'en passe un petit bout dans
le spectacle et j'ai mis de ses
intérieurs puis je parle de lui je parle
des pochons je parlé mais ce qui est
marrant c'est que ce jour là quand il
est venu il a fait un truc génial que
tout ira dans une émission
une fois qu émission était fini on s'est
aperçu qu'il avait commandé à bouffer et
à boire pour tous les techniciens qui
avaient fait l'émission sans rien dire à
personne et on va il avait inventé et
tous les techniciens et n'a à boire et à
manger comme cyril séance
sauf que nous ces décès les pizzas ça va
arriver
j'ai un dernier petit truc pour toi ces
quatre jeunes kanaks lot qui m'a envoyé
un petit message et qui te remercie
encore pour tout ce que tu as fait pour
sa carrière indien seul envoyez le mot
qui nous regardent en direct et voulait
de faire un gros bisou monsieur du fury
gros bisous à mon jeu voilà mon jet et à
jean bart
[Applaudissements]